today's video was made possible thanks
to masterworks stagflation i'm sure you
hear this word all the time a dangerous
cocktail of high inflation coupled with
unemployment and a slowdown in economic
growth with inflation soaring to seven
eight maybe even a whopping nine percent
the threat of stagflation is real and
how can we protect our savings in the
face of this unstoppable stagflation
well there is no one simple answer but
diversification always seems to be one
of the most sensible options in terms of
protection and as jp morgan recently
pointed out alternative assets are here
to stay in this diversification process
and what better example of an
alternative asset than the art
marketplace this is where masterworks
comes in masterworks gives everyone
access to a market that was previously
inaccessible to the average person art
here's how the process works masterworks
analytics team studies thousands of
pieces of data to find financially
attractive works with appreciation
potential then they buy them for amounts
ranging from one million dollars to 30
million dollars and securitize them by
filing and offering circular through the
sec finally they hold the work for three
to ten years until it is sold but is art
profitable well this market has
appreciated by a not inconsiderable 14
in recent years in fact from 1995 to
2021 it achieved better data than the s
p 500 including dividends but be careful
it's very important to remember no one
can really predict the future and past
results do not assure future returns if
you want to take a look at masterworks
for yourself here is a link that will
allow you to skip the waiting list and
as always when it comes to anything
investing be very careful there is no
such thing as a risk-free investment
[Music]
[Music]
missiles that fall down randomly fighter
jets that cannot fire because they have
no ammunition and soldiers fed with
expired food you could be mistaken for
believing that this is the plot of a
hotshot style comedy but in reality
we're talking about the russian invasion
of ukraine for years we all thought that
russia had an enviable defense industry
yes it's true the russian economy is
nothing to write home about this is a
country incapable of exporting high
value-added products such as cars cell
phones or software but the defense
industry was the jaw in russia's crown
to give you an idea russia has between
2.5 and 3 million people working in arms
manufacturing that accounts for 20 of
the country's industrial jobs in other
words it seemed that armament was the
exception that proves the usual rule in
russia the only industry that was really
working
this is what putin showed us every year
at military parades every 9th of may
russia celebrates the victory in world
war ii or as they say in russian the
great patriotic war moscow's red square
fills with people to see their army's
newest weaponry incredible sukhoi su-34
fighter jets perform aerobatics modern
armata tanks roll through the streets
and the whole world shudders as putin
shows off his nuclear bombs in front of
the kremlin yes visualpolitik fans we
all thought russia had the military
muscle to be able to take over ukraine
in just a matter of days however the
real way to test a country's military
power is not in a parade but a real war
and with the invasion of ukraine we are
seeing something that has become the
norm in the russian economy something
like an expectation versus reality meme
us assesses up to 60 failure rate for
some russian missiles officials say yes
visual politic viewers after a month of
the ukraine invasion we can say it
clearly russian armament falls far
behind the expectations and hype they
had created and this is a surprise
because since 2008 putin's main priority
has been the modernization of his army
remember that we are talking about a
country that has been spending more than
five percent of its gdp on defense for
some years as a comparison germany has
just announced that it is going to spend
two percent and it seems to us a
historic measure in other words russia
has poured all of its resources into
improving its weaponry it is true that
no one expected the russian arsenal to
surpass that of the united states but
compared to any other country russia
appeared to be in the military vanguard
however we are seeing that this armament
is a real disaster
[Music]
you could say russia has spent billions
of rubles in manufacturing weapons that
have turned out to be nothing more than
rubble the question is why what on earth
has gone wrong with russia's military
industry why despite investing so much
money does russia maintain such an
obsolete arsenal today we're going to
answer these questions but first would
you like to receive exclusive
visualpolitik merchandise inc photos
products that are not for sale anywhere
well now you can the only way to get our
merchandising is to be part of our
patreon community if you support us at
patreon at tier 4 or above you will not
only get merchandising but you will also
receive our weekly political analysis
newsletter as well as a lot of
additional content and topics that we
can't cover in our usual visual politics
videos if you want to enjoy all of this
content i'll see you on patreon and now
let's take a look at some history
[Music]
capitalism without private companies
[Music]
what is the most famous assault rifle in
the world exactly the ak-47 better known
as the kalashnikov is it better known as
the kalashnikov or is it better known as
the ak-47 we'll let you argue that one
in the comments as you probably all know
the kalashnikov is of soviet
manufacturer with such an icon of the
defense industry many of you would think
that the soviet union had a world-class
arms industry however the reality was
quite different almost every weapon in
the soviet arsenal can be summed up in
one meme there is a world of difference
between expectation versus reality
[Music]
the soviet military industry was full of
unprofitable state enterprises obsolete
factories and above all a great deal of
corruption you see in the united states
there is an alliance between government
and private companies we have told you
about it several times on visualpolitik
there is the example of the f-35
washington that needed to renew its
fleet of fighter jets well broadly
speaking they held a tender in which
several private companies submitted bids
in this case the main candidates were
boeing and lockheed martin in the end
lockheed martin won the competition and
was awarded a contract worth millions of
dollars of course this system has its
problems private companies want to
maximize their profit that explains the
spiraling cost overruns on the f35 we're
talking about more than 400 billion us
dollars that have come out of the u.s
taxpayer's pocket to swell the bottom
line of a private company of course
there are many aspects of the system
that we can criticize but with all of
its problems this system has made
american companies capable of developing
the most advanced weaponry in the world
it is a result of decades of competition
between companies
soviet communism was based on the
opposite idea the entire economy
depended on the state defence was based
on state monopolies the results are
there for all to see but i know what you
are all thinking josh the soviet union
disappeared 30 plus years ago russia has
abandoned communism and nobody in their
right mind would say that vladimir putin
is a die-hard communist and yes you're
right for decades russia has been in a
system that has very little to do with
the bolshevik revolution even so russia
has never embraced free market
capitalism we have talked about this a
thousand times on visualpolitik although
russia abandoned communism decades ago
it still maintains a highly centralized
economy the state still maintains a
pivotal role in all industries and that
includes obviously armaments and yes you
are right the question is what is the
problem is it really so important that
weapons are manufactured by private
companies how can a country's entire
military arsenal be modernized without
competition between companies well we're
going to look at that right now
zelovicky thinking
[Music]
i know what many of you are thinking if
you want your companies to be
competitive the best thing to do is to
privatize them so that they can compete
with each other right this is what free
market economic logic would say but
putin's russia has a very different
logic according to vladimir putin the
problem with communism was not the
centralized economy but an economy based
on ideological principles in other words
if you want to improve the efficiency of
the system it is enough to change the
managers and put technocrats in charge
technocrats who have been forged in the
bosom of the kgb and who have a
pragmatic mentality totally free of the
romanticism of communism or any other
ideology this type of person has a name
silovicky and so just what was putin's
formula for bringing his military
industry into the 21st century very
simple to put silo vicki's in all
managerial positions this is how rostec
was conceived in 2007 a conglomerate of
companies designed to be the great
umbrella of russian defense under this
umbrella are more than 700 armaments
companies all of them state-owned
by grouping companies together a lot of
duplication can be eliminated all
following purely technocratic criteria
and who is the ceo of rostock none other
than sergey chemezov who was a colleague
of vladimir putin himself when they were
both in the kgb offices in east germany
in other words a textbook silo vicky and
you will ask so has rostec really
managed to eliminate costs well yes it
has to give you an idea in 2008 all the
companies under the rostec umbrella had
a combined workforce of
788 000 in 2014 there were only 443 000
workers since its founding rostec has
not stopped absorbing all kinds of arms
companies it has even allowed private
capital to enter some of russia's major
arms companies let me give you an
example the makers of the legendary
ak-47 a massive 74 percent of jsc
kalashnikov concern is in private hands
however rustic's expansion has a problem
by acquiring more and more companies
rustic has ended up consolidating even
more monopolies for example fighter jets
the united states works with four major
manufacturers boeing lockheed martin
raytheon and airbus yes airbus is
european but it also has contracts with
washington in the case of russia
practically all fighter jets are
manufactured by the same company uac
which of course is under the umbrella of
rostec and you will say is it really
enough to put a silo vicky at the head
of a monopoly to make it more
competitive well just for yourselves
another major russian defense company is
almas ante this company does not depend
on rustic but is directly owned by the
russian ministry of finance the ceo of
this company is another textbook silo
vicki in this case we are talking about
victor ivanov another former kgb agent
almas ante is the giant where npo
novator the manufacturer of almost all
russian precision missiles is located
yes those very missiles that are proving
to be so flawed in the invasion of
ukraine and the truth is that none of
this is much of a surprise to give you
an idea in 2017 npo novata could only
produce 60 caliber missiles in six
months as you can imagine these figures
are ridiculous if we take into account
that in just one month of war russia has
launched more than 1 200 missiles
but aren't there any private companies
in the entire russian defense complex
well yes there are for example do you
remember the expired cans of food
supplied to the soldiers at the front
well pay attention
navalny unmasks a cartel allegedly
earning billions in russian defense
deals guess which cartel we are talking
about that's right it's a network of
catering companies owned by evgeny
pragopsin who surprise surprise is a
personal friend of putin this fine
gentleman is a chef who owns restaurants
and catering companies as alexey navalny
reported pragotzin dodged all public
tender systems to become the army's
caterer now today navalny is in jail and
russian soldiers are receiving expired
cans of food and the question many of
you must be asking now is hang on you
said that the missile factory was only
capable of producing 60 precision units
in six months but russia has launched
more than 1 200 missiles on the
battlefield how is that possible where
did they get so many missiles from well
we're going to explain that right now
theory versus reality
the question on every military analyst's
mind at the moment is how is it possible
that russia has not been able to achieve
air supremacy that is how is it possible
that russia has not been able to destroy
all of ukraine's anti-aircraft defenses
so that russian fighters can bomb
without any problems think about it
ukraine has only 134 fighter jets and
they are all from the soviet era russia
has almost 1 200 fighters 300 of which
are ready to attack ukraine we are
talking moreover about modern fighter
jets remember that russia has invested
billions in modernizing its military and
that includes the air force there is for
example the sukhoi su-34 these fighters
are bombers that came into use in 2008.
on paper these fighter bombers would
rival the f-15e of the united states we
could say that they are one of russia's
best fighters the problem is that they
barely have enough precision ammunition
to shoot it may sound ridiculous but all
the data indicates that russia does not
have enough precision munitions for this
war it may come as a surprise to you but
precision missiles they have a shelf
life
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right each one of those missiles
fired by an aircraft has a lifespan of
10 to 15 years that means if you want to
go to war your weapons factories had
better be manufacturing at full capacity
however as we have already seen russian
factories have a lot of problems with
mass production well these late model
sukhoi su-34s have been firing
conventional ammunition what we might
call dumb bombs that is they fall where
they fall that could explain such
terrible news stories as this
three dead as maternity hospital hit by
russian air strike think about it
attacking a maternity hospital is not
only an atrocity it is also a tactical
failure the objective of an attack is to
destroy enemy defenses killing children
in a hospital besides being savage
serves no strategic objective put
another way this attack is not the fruit
of an evil general who wants to kill
children is the result of not having
precision missiles well we're not just
talking about poorly planned attacks
having few precision missiles poses
another problem for aircraft it forces
them to fly low and as you can imagine
if a fighter jet flies low it becomes an
easy target for any anti-missile cannon
the russian air force is losing its best
jets over ukraine exactly russia's best
planes are dropping like flies because
they don't have adequate ammunition
[Music]
something similar has happened with
tanks russia already lost more than 400
tanks in this war what's more we are
already seeing how even the logistics
are being done with civilian trucks all
of this explains why the invasion of
ukraine has left us with images as
comical as this one
i know what many of you are thinking
let's get this straight josh are you
really saying that the russians are
stupid and have gone to war without
ammunition well no the problem is not
that the russians are stupid the problem
is that a political system with bad
incentives generates nothing but failure
we have said it more than once on
visualpolitik the russian economy is
designed so that no business can get out
from under the control of putin and his
elites in that sense russia is totally
efficient however when it comes to
innovation the cielo vicki's are
incapable of generating results so once
again we find that there is a world of
difference between silo vicky
expectation and reality and the truth is
that this is not the first time either
do you remember the russian vaccine
against the coronavirus the famous
sputnik v
[Music]
on paper the vaccine worked that is the
design and the formula were correct i
don't know if you remember but at a time
there was a worldwide debate about the
effectiveness of the russian vaccine
today no one is talking about this
vaccine anymore and it is not even
approved by the who in other words it is
very likely that the russian defense
industry is full of cases like the
sputnik v vaccine we are talking about
combat fighters that on the drawing
board are technological prodigies but
have no ammunition late tank models that
cannot be mass produced because there
are no factories available precision
missiles that are not as accurate as
they appeared to be and so on and so
forth are failed projects for years
putin's entourage has been hiding the
flaws but now that we are seeing the
effectiveness of these weapons on the
battlefield we are seeing that all the
assumptions we had about the russian
economy are true now only one question
remains and i leave it for you to answer
in the comments what about russia's
nuclear weaponry we all know that russia
has the largest nuclear arsenal in the
world putin has even threatened to use
it the question is does it really work
what if many of those warheads are out
of date are those intercontinental
missiles really as effective as the
kremlin claims of course none of us want
to put that to the test but what do you
think is it more russian hype you can
leave me your answers in the comments
below and as always don't forget that
here on visualpolitik we release new
videos every week so subscribe to this
channel hit that little bell icon down
there so you don't miss any of our
updates and if you like this video give
it a like and i'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
[Music]
you